In Iran, in a rare address at Friday prayers, Supreme Leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei...
...said that Iran's missile strikes on US targets in Iraq showed it had divine support...
...in delivering a "slap on the face" to a world power.
In Ukraine, the prime minister offered his resignation on Friday...
...after an audio recording was leaked in which he was heard making disparaging comments...
...about the president's understanding of the economy.
In Libya, the commander of opposition forces in Libya, General Khalifa Hifter,...
...visited Athens to counter Turkey's support of the UN-backed government of Libya...
...just two days before a Berlin peace conference,...
...where both sides are expected to attend.
In Myanmar, President Win Myint welcomes Chinese President Xi Jinping...
...as he kicks off a two-day visit to the Southeast Asian country.
Finally from Australia,...
...koalas at an Australian wildlife park were rescued from flash flooding,...
...a week after thousands died in the path of raging bushfires.